a lot of people were very critical of
Sal yesterday not taking lipitor for his
high cholesterol of 300 he's so back
yeah there was a theory kicking around
the office yesterday that I think might
be true we looked up lipitor and we
think the reason Sal didn't take it
because as many things there's a hundred
things that could go wrong it may cause
hair loss and we think so so that that's
it oh okay so you'd rather have a heart
attack and die then get lose any hair
mark come on guy that's a pretty good
area probably scared the crap out of you
you spend a lot of money getting some
air
imagine like there's a war between the
lipitor in his body and the propecia
I'll be a good cartoon propecia versus
lipitor and we see what happens with
Sal's hair really what you hear yeah but
you had the hair transit Steve what they
call the native hairs the original hairs
like the Native Americans his native
hair you mean your native I know it
sounds odd but the doctor calls it
native hairs tell me what the doctor
said explained to me because I don't
know anything about okay so I said to
the doc I go what's going on here I paid
a shitload of money and still falling
out it goes no the plugs are not falling
out the native hairs are falling out the
original hair of course the native hairs
are funny funny like you're gonna be
left with like a bunch of plugs I know
you're no native no native hair I got
like a Barbie doll that was like dragged
through with the mud or something so is
he going to give you more hair plugs I'm
thinking about going back but I don't
know I'll wait it out a little bit how
long is this been going on I noticed
within the past three months and it's
gradually getting worse and worse worse
every time the light hits the top of my
head it looks shinier and shinier and
I'm seeing more scalp I did what'd you
do I bought hair powder I've been
spraying it in over the spa I'll have
you yes it's been pretty good and they
do anything like just give you more tons
and tons and tons of hair plugs to the
point that you just all
plugs I think I could yeah Gary's theory
isn't crazy that's probably why you
don't want to use lipitor you can knock
out your cocktail function so even in
ten milligrams knowing you some [ __ ]
function would be good to lose your
[ __ ] busy putting that dick every
where
well Howard don't get mad at me but I
did some more research and I'm thinking
about purchasing red yeast rice it's not
you haven't figured out yet i'ma talk
Robin it could be something here yeah
red rice rice it's a natural stat and it
contains the same properties of lipitor
but doesn't have it's not you know it's
not medically produced it's not produced
in a lab you know and what is said and
where do you get this on Amazon said yes
you take every whack-ass thing free to
grow your hair you'll even order stuff
from China that isn't approved but you
won't take lipitor but I stopped taking
all that stuff - yeah it's not that it
won't take lipitor I'm trying to avoid
it and see if there's a your cholesterol
is 300 dude that's crazy that's stroke
time milk now my coffee
I think JD laughing what's your
cholesterol JD where's the last time you
had a checkup
[Music]
what get near the microphone I'll take
that pill for high blood pressure
oh you are but your cholesterol was okay
anything to me about it so what's your
blood pressure number I rejected but
like last time I was like 119 over 80
something with the pill yeah dude what
was your
like when I'm talking to me runs away
from the microphone you went to the
doctor originally and he puts you on
high blood pressure medication what was
your blood pressure like 140 over like
107 or something that's not good
you're fat [ __ ] I'm trying to scare you
straight sounds gonna have a [ __ ]
stroke or a heart attack
now you're researching medicine what did
you say to yourself maybe I'm the wrong
guy to research nope I mean you know
don't try and try again you know what I
mean now we don't